[Music]
several years ago the World Health
Organization declared that it wasn't
cost-effective to help people get
treatment for drug-resistant
tuberculosis and there was an
organization called Partners in Health
that said simply refuse to accept this
claim they said we're gonna do whatever
it takes to help these people so they
came up with a program for treating
drug-resistant tuberculosis in some of
the world's most conflict-ridden poorest
places and they succeeded in doing it
they had very good treatment outcomes so
they thought creatively about how to
come up with treatment programs that
worked
and as a result funding for a
drug-resistant TB increased
spectacularly and now many people around
the world have treatment so what did
they do I think what they did is they
have this virtue which requires three
things first that we commit to
fulfilling human rights second that we
think creatively or imagine ways of
doing that and finally that we act to do
so so let me explain the virtue of
creative resolve a little bit more and
hopefully you'll see why I think it's
really important so first to have the
virtue one has to question evidence
against the possibility of fulfilling
Human Rights we can do this in many ways
so we can question the source
reliability or implications of that
evidence it's possible to acquiesce too
quickly in the face of evidence that
it's impossible to help people or to be
so pigheaded that we refuse to accept
the constraints of the given the second
thing that we need to do is I think
consider all of the options on the table
and then use our imagination to come up
with new options finally we should act
to fulfill human rights and this
requires a measure of grit will or
resoluteness we can't be inflexible and
persists even when it is actually
impossible to fulfill rights but at the
same time we shouldn't be complacent
about it since change is difficult
people who don't think
it's possible or desirable to fulfill
human rights probably won't try hard to
do so so hope is important for the
virtue of creative resolve hope is
simply believing something that one
desires is possible but not certain
still even when we lack a kind of hope I
think we should have the virtue of
creative resolve as long as there is not
conclusive evidence that fulfilling
Human Rights is impossible so the kind
of hope we need is a radical hope in the
face of uncertainty we we must process
it exercise our moral imaginations to
help people meet their basic needs but
the reason we should have creative
resolve is this the ground for the human
rights is protecting everybody's ability
to live a dignified human life and it's
really important that we do that so we
should try hard
I think the imperative to try hard is
particularly compelling given that
there's a lot of psychological evidence
that people don't try hard enough they
tend to search - not far enough for
solutions to problems and many people
seem to have a narrow view of
possibility and feasibility assuming
tight timeframes and financial
constraints when we imagine ourselves
succeeding in tasks were often more
likely to do so perhaps because our
imagination Spurs a sense of agency and
lets us set plans for the future and act
to achieve them the crux of my
disagreement with critics of the human
right to health who think we have to
ration and that the human right has to
tell us how to do that is this I don't
think that's what the human rights
health has to do or even that it should
rather I think it does something much
more important for us I think it
inspires us to do our best to help
everyone meet their basic needs ok but
if we do have to ration here's what I
think I think creative resolve can help
us do that I think it can help us find
better ways of helping more people we
can't though simply build hospitals in
the city rather than also in the
countryside because it's most cost
effective to do that everybody has a
human right to health and if we think
creatively enough about how to do it we
may be able to help everybody okay so
there's two sides to this virtue on the
one side we should try very hard to help
people fulfill their human rights on the
other side we don't have to try when
it's impossible or impermissible to do
that but I'm going to stress and I have
been stressing the positive or
commitment side of the virtue for this
reason millions of people around the
world are suffering and dying every year
from poverty related causes and it's not
as if there's millions of people trying
to help them I believe we need to try
harder try harder try harder I think we
need to find both the resources and the
political will to do this and like
Martin Luther King we should refuse to
believe that the bank of Justice is
[Music]